[Music]
as we continue our series i
on earth we're introducing you to one
organization that isn't waiting for
congress
to take action on climate change the
solutions project co-founded by
by award-winning actor mark ruffalo aims
to transition to 100 percent
clean renewable energy for everyone by
2050. that's coming up the project has
supported and funded more than 100
grassroots organizations ninety-five
percent of which are run by people of
color
my name is rauker matsian my name is
nathaniel smith i am suzanne singer i am
the executive director of native
renewables
and my grandparents were among the 15
000
families that lack access to electricity
on the navajo nation and that's why i
founded native renewables we've been
able to install several
off-grid solar systems for families and
that's been really exciting because we
can see them turn the light on for the
very first time
the partnership with southern equity
works to advance a new southern agenda
for racial equity and shared prosperity
but we're educating
communities of color to be more active
and involved
in their own destiny by way of advocacy
as relates to climate and energy issues
this is amazing
push buffalo is a frontline community
based organization that is mobilizing
residents to create strong neighborhoods
and we build affordable housing
we build community-owned renewable
energy projects everything we do
at push buffalo is rooted in addressing
climate justice our next project is
going to be 49 units of affordable
housing
with 30 supportive housing and they will
be built
with no fossil fuel infrastructure in
buffalo new york
we're grateful to the solutions project
they have just been not only a funder
but but a great ally it's a real
authentic
relationship that honors the wisdom that
frontline communities like ours know
what they want where they live
and that we're already leading with real
solutions for real people
mark ruffalo and the solutions project
president and ceo gloria walton join us
now
uh good morning to you uh mark i want to
start with you as a co-founder of the
solutions project
uh you know climate change is obviously
a global issue but the focus of the
project is on
local actors how did it come about and
why that strategy
uh well thanks for having us on um it's
great to be here
talking about the good news uh of of
uh this moment we're living in i i
moved my family to upstate new york
right in the
moment that um they were gonna put 55
000
uh fracking wells uh in my community
and so um my experience of this is is
from
the front line my community
had to fight um with very little
resources it was a rural community
and we had to fight literally for our
lives and our children's lives
it was poison the air and the water and
would create an enormous amount of
pollution and
what i saw was how efficient
how effective that kind of organizing
was
and um how little resources
you needed to actually create change and
we not only did we ban fracking but we
also pushed the state to 100
renewable energy with the um the most
progressive
um legislation in the nation
on transitioning away from dirty fossil
fuels yeah
and so i saw the power of
community organizing to actually affect
change and
um and implement the the um
the change that needs to happen in order
for us to
thrive in this new um climate reality
crisis hey gloria we just heard mark say
that he's happy to talk about the good
news of this particular moment that
we're living through i think a lot of
people will be surprised to hear there
is good news
from where you're sitting there as
president of the solutions project
what do you like what do you see
oh wow so so much
um to mark's point this is a
moment where we have the president of
the united states saying
environmental justice and that has
everything to do
with the decades of organizing and power
building in front line communities
i particularly feel like we're in a
moment um
that i should speak to right a moment of
racial reckoning
and you know i think about how racism
pollution and poverty are interconnected
and in this time of racial reckoning i
feel like climate justice really
is an opportunity to transform our
systems
in a way that leaves no communities
behind so
and i say this gloria i just want to say
because you say
racial justice is an essential part of
tackling climate change
can you make that connection how does
that work yes
great question tony so uh
it's no coincidence that the same
communities that are criminalized and
dying at the hands of police officers
who swore to protect and serve us are
the very same communities that are first
and worst impacted by climate change and
that's not by
chance so decisions have been made to
create a lot of conditions that black
indigenous asian american and pacific
islander and other people of color
communities are living with
and these communities have a history of
being under resourced
and it's not coincidence that these
communities are often
surrounded in living adjacent to
freeways
oil drilling fracking sites and even
petrochemical plants
and so the air quality is often bad and
highly polluted
and what that means is that these
communities have higher rates of asthma
and other respiratory illnesses cancer
and even higher rates of
mortality right than white communities
and so when you look at something like
cobit for example
and they're saying how these same
communities are disproportionately
impacted it's not coincidence that these
are the same communities that are on the
front lines of environmental degradation
right and so if your lungs are already
compromised
if you get covered you're going to be
one of the sickest right and so for
generations
uh environmental justice communities or
as we like to call it frontline
communities those most impacted and
closest to the problems
are often the first to the solutions and
in fact are innovating
transformative climate solutions that
are tackling multiple problems at once
so they're creating living wage grain
jobs
training opportunities affordable
housing powered by
solar addressing public health by
fighting for policies to improve air
quality
advocating to keep oil in the ground and
putting buffer zones between where
families live and children play and so
this is a moment where our government
and corporate industry leaders need to
be looking to the expertise and
innovation happening in front line
communities
it's time to invest and scale
community-centered and community-led
solutions
gloria walton mark ruffalo we appreciate
you both for joining us thank you very
much mark can i just say i loved you and
i know this much is true congratulations
on your mate you were so good
i thought if he doesn't win something's
wrong has nothing to do with climate
change but you were awesome
nice to meet you thank you very much i
know we got to go we gotta go thank you
both
we're watching cbs this morning we'll be
right back